anime has been popular for quite some
time and there are loads of shows to
choose from so how about i give you some
recommendations on what i feel are the
best action anime every year of the past
decade or so no movies or ovas just tv
series and no sequels each year has a
lot of strong contenders but i'll single
out the one that i think is the best
among them it's all my opinion but hey
maybe you can finally make the decision
to try out that show that you've been
putting on hold for quite some time
already before we get started i urge you
to subscribe to the channel it just
takes a second to do it and if you're
still unsure about it maybe this video
will convince you to hit that button and
be the first in line for my next upload
2011
ah what a year for anime while most
people will remember this year for three
smash hits stein's gate fate zero and
marduka magicka i think that the action
anime of the year is none other than
hunter hunter it's really a close call
between this and fate zero which two of
my personal favorites
these shows really push the boundary of
what we typically associate with action
anime people tend to associate fate zero
with a dark and cynical outlook on
things and it's amazing animation and
art which still actually hold up now the
directing superb and the voice actors
really do an amazing job still i
narrowly give the edge to hunter hunter
for being more of a straight up
adventure series that i could recommend
to anyone accessibility to the new anime
fan looking for their first show is good
and i think hunter hunter 2011 is one of
the remakes that really improved on its
original material it's also a bright
adventure that can smoothly shift to
dark and serious tones with a lot of
philosophical backdrops honourable
mentions this year include blue exorcist
and dead man wonderland i also enjoyed
the polarizing guilty crown and future
diary a lot and i'd say that those shows
had their moments too they're not
popular shows without a reason
2012
2012 is officially where i think the
isakai craze got its start when reiki
gavahara became a household name
axel world from early this year got a
middling reception but it soared our
online to the anime world by storm
behind sao and axel world there are a
lot of action shows that i enjoyed here
urobuchi continued his momentum from
2011 with the ever popular psycho pass
and i found myself loving the ellen
action harem jewel of high school dxd
and oda nobuna unless we forget magi
which i feel is one of the more
underrated shonen for the quality of its
world building and writing but for 2012
i give the crown to jojo
why well jojo's pretty much one of the
most beloved shonen franchises out there
these days and this is when it's anime
started it combines a lot of your
typical hot blooded shown in action with
super over the top powers and execution
that would put even trigger to shame but
it's not just the craziness that it's
got going for it jojo has a legitimately
interesting overarching plot that spans
multiple seasons and in universe
generations it's a quintessential action
series that you might want to check out
2013.
speaking of trigger 2013 is where their
big hit killer kill made its debut if
you want to talk controversial this is
the year rave came out personally i
obviously love the action light novel
shows with harem elements i found my
thirst for that quench with some rather
niche titles like data live machine doll
and strike the blood but we all know
what 2013 is all about kill la kill
largely considered one of the best shows
in that era paled in popularity compared
to the blockbuster of that year
2013's the year of
attack on titan no questions asked with
its very intriguing premise of survival
its action horror ambiance and how it
goes out of the way to create a high
octane action show devoid of the usual
anime tropes that non-fans could find
weird attack on titan made its mark all
over the world i dare say that it's
probably the year anime really started
to burst into the mainstream i'd also
say sao got the ball rolling but at the
end with the tropes that used the fan
service and how it wrote the characters
it's still a show obviously made to be
enjoyed by the more otaku side of the
fandom however attack on titan shattered
all boundaries that kept the normies
away from the community it also helps
the attack on titan throughout its
seasons constantly found ways to
reinvent itself it hooked the people
with the survival horror premise of
season 1 and while the premise of humans
fighting titans persisted towards the
end of the next seasons you'll find that
the show has dared to branch into a lot
of other areas like politics morals and
humanity
this was truly a landmark year for anime
2014.
unfortunately with how much attack on
titan took over the anime world it's
hard to make a break through the year
after that and it's a shame because 2014
did have a lot of great action shows
this was the year seven deadly sins
started and it was a legitimately fun
action show before it got meme to death
thanks to the subpar art and animation
in the latter seasons there's also
noragami and tokyo ghoul and of course
how could i not mention my two light
novel hits of the year mahoka and no
game no life the former had the luck to
get a second season and an animated
spin-off the latter well not so much at
least no game no lights movie blows
majors out of the water as a final
honorable mention i also enjoyed black
bullet despite being grossly
disappointed in the adaptation's cut
content as a source material reader
however you see the problem besides
noragami none of the shows above can be
easily recommended to non-anime fans
tokyo ghoul feels a tad bit too edgy for
the average normie while the others have
fan service that those same people
likely wouldn't take too kindly to
thankfully though 2014 also gave us my
action anime of the year
parasite
parasite often gets compared to tokyo
gore with its edgy action style but i
feel that parasite maintains more of a
better balance between the violence and
the message behind the plot it feels
more relevant to society as a whole and
i really like how the characters
developed also while it's not a knock on
tokyo ghoul's first season which is
really enjoyable parasite at least
wrapped up its story neatly in its one
and only season whereas the other show
required multiple seasons the latter
ones which were rushed to oblivion if
you know someone who's never touched
anime before and wanted to recommend a
show from 2014 then parasite is my pick
before we move on to our next entry ever
had a situation where you wanted to
watch the titles i recommend but you
find yourself unable to do it legally
well that sounds like a job for
everyone's best friend on the go and the
sponsors of this video expressvpn ever
wanted to bypass region locks and watch
more anime ever wanted to access
facebook or reddit in places where
they're blocked you know who to call if
you're still not convinced then hear me
out as a person who enjoyed traveling
back in the days expressvpn became my
best buddy all i needed to do was
connect to a server of my choosing and
voila now movies like your name and
spirited away are just a click away you
can try it yourself and it is as easy as
it looks the only thing separating you
from watching the next episode of your
favorite anime in a foreign country is
the click of a button in addition to
bypassing region locks express vpn also
provides outstanding protection from the
dangers of the internet expressvpn is
here to act as your unbeatable shield
against those cyber attacks to get your
super cheap express vpn subscription
just follow the link in the description
box or type in expressvpn.com
vinnie tube to get started
2015.
2015 is yet another big year for action
anime
arslan overlord and danmachi take the
forefront for action novel adaptations
but there are also some other novel
adaptation hits like chivalry of a
failed knight and the polarizing gate
and asterisk war
also there's a personal guilty pleasure
and favorite of mine testament of sister
new devil on the manga side of things we
have assassination classroom making its
big debut and i myself have a soft spot
for saraf of the end despite people back
then passing it off as an attack on
titan ripoff with bleach weapons and gay
vampires but 2015 undoubtedly belongs to
one punch man it's not quite attack on
titan in terms of how big of a cultural
phenomenon it became but one punch man
seriously came pretty damn close to it
attack on titan as i said broke the
barrier between anime fans and ordinary
people and one punch man was the show
perfectly poised to capitalize on that
at this time superheroes were becoming
the in thing thanks to the excellence of
the mcu and the general awareness of
them growing and whether by chance or by
intention one punch man really did take
advantage of that it also helps that
while the show is an exciting action
series through and through it does
deliver the goods as a parody it's a
show that would at first be passed off
as comedy due to how it pokes fun at the
ridiculousness of shonen anime yet at
the same time become such an immersive
and emotional roller coaster when you do
actually watch it the hype is real for
one punch man and while season two is
quite middling season one during its
time was a legitimate cultural
phenomenon
2016.
how fitting for 2016 to be yet another
win for the creator one if 2015 is one
punch man's year the crown for 2016 goes
to mob psycho with all the shows that
i've talked about so far mob psycho
could probably boast the title of being
the best in his much renowned animation
however animation doesn't make an anime
and luckily for mob psycho it's got so
much more going for it it's got a very
simple yet exciting storyline and his
characters are all interesting and well
written
character dynamics and the action really
make mob psycho feel like a cinematic
production more than anything people
have compared this amazing show to a
comic book flick and it's not hard to
see why when i was quick to give mob
psycho the crown i won't pretend it was
an easy win given what 2016 gave us
superheroes never went out of flavor and
the year introduced my hero academia a
show which is still going strong to this
day to the world it's also had a
plethora of knee shows that i really
enjoyed such as 91 days elder ramen in
the sky bungo stray dogs twin star
exorcists and drifters do you classify
re zero as action because that's
actually certainly one of the strongest
contenders for the year given how much i
love it hey i even made a video essay on
that so you can check that out in the
upper right corner
2017
compared to the previous years 2017
seemed more like a lull in terms of
action anime honestly speaking and
that's if we exclude sequels movies and
ovas but don't get me wrong though
there's still quite a lot to like such
as yujo senki the year also gave us
recreators inuyashiki fade apocrypha and
akashic records it's just that besides
yujo senki none of these feel as if they
made a big impact on the community is
something like uh overlord or one punch
man and that's not to discredit the 2017
shows but it just goes to show that if
you take the sequels which included
attack on titan out of the way the year
felt quiet as far as action shows go
that is relative and it's more of a
testament to what blockbusters the
preceding year gave us for my 2017 pick
i'll direct you to a hidden gem of an
anime pun intended in land of the
lustrous the premise is simple enough
you're given a cast of humanoid gems who
fight for survival against enemies who
abduct them and turn them into jewelry
however you see the story unfold through
the lens of one who's not exactly a
fighter through foss's perspective we're
then given a show that heavily deals
with tragedy self-image and loss it's
more than an action show and it's an
anime that i can confidently introduce
to a non-fan at least compared to
something like yujosenki the 3d
presentation might discourage some
people from watching the show but it is
actually surprisingly well done if i
were to look at an action show as a
whole in terms of value and not just
popcorn entertainment land of the
lustrous easily takes the top spot this
year
2018
as we inch closer to the end of the
decade we start getting into the action
shows that made a buzz in the community
for good or bad reasons who could forget
goblin slayer's controversy or the
weekly reactions darling in the
frankstra of the community this year
also marked golden kamui's debut and
while its focus is more exploration and
adventure it's got some good action and
it's one of the shows that i just
couldn't get enough of slime also
started this year and it's poised to be
one of the big isekai hits in the coming
years as far as anime adaptations go if
we're talking straight action that can
see some mainstream appeal to non-fans i
think that few can top megalo box for
that year combining a lot of classic
western aesthetics with an epic boxing
setting made for a wondrous addition to
the library of action anime people have
called it an exciting anime that looked
like a heavy sci-fi cross between cowboy
bebop and samurai shamplo and it's easy
to see why it has its own unique style
from the presentation to the music and
has that nostalgic 90s feel that a lot
of people have grown to love but one of
the main reasons i'd recommend this
anime to someone is because how amazing
the second season which he had this year
was and don't get me wrong the first
season was good and all but the second
season for me is just on another tier
easily won the best anime of 2021 so far
so in a different twist megalo box is
actually something that i would
recommend more to older fans those who
went through the 90s and had taken a
break from anime it should bring back
memories of those good old days that
they'll surely enjoy reliving
2019
right so we all know what 2019's about
but first let me talk about the
honorable mentions first up i had a
great time watching dororo fireforce and
shield hero and i'd recommend those to
anime fans wise man's grandchild is also
a fun show to watch although it only
caters to a specific niche so i can't
easily recommend that one as much the
same can be said of ari furetha but this
one also had the dubious distinction of
possibly some of the worst cg in
animation i've seen in an anime for a
long time
ps1 monsters in 2019 anyone
we all know 2019 is the year of demon
slayer breaking into the mainstream like
nothing's ever done before heck i think
the demon slayer craze has officially
surpassed attack on titan with the manga
the opening song and even the recent
movie shattering records left and right
but
i give the nod this year
to vinland saga i just feel that as an
action series finland sanger just brings
so much more to the table than demon
slayer i can understand why the latter
became more popular but where vinland
saga lacked in the flashy explosive ufo
table animations and cool powers it
brought with a more grounded and
complete story the way i see it the
narrative gets developed better and the
characters are a tier above demon
slayer's characters in terms of writing
and characterization i'm not saying that
demons say characters are bad or bland
because that's not the case the finland
saga's cast just feels way better if
we're going to look at it from a
critical perspective a captivating story
of hardship and growth filled with epic
action of very complex characters
finland saga's my pick for 2019's action
anime
2020
we come to the end of the decade 2020
for me will always be the year of delays
due to the real world circumstances as
well as the year of sequels if we take
all the sequels movies and ovas out the
way you're actually left with a few gems
i had a blast with the trio of edgy
action titles dora hidaro darwin's game
and gleipnir the dragon quest anime was
also fun and the duo of princess connect
and both three are probably two of my
favorite chill action shows the past
year but things would change in this
rather slow year for non-sequels as it
marched towards the end with what i can
feel to be suspiciously demon slayer's
spiritual successor jujutsu kaizen
no the two shows aren't related but i
think the demon slayer's smashing
success had a bit to do with jiu jitsu
kaizen getting the green light i mean
there's also the revival of shaman king
and bleach not long after it's like that
time when many shows with the attack on
titan approach got green lit giving us
galvaneri of the iron fortress black
bullet seraph of the end and gordita
whatever the case though supernatural
actions shonen are back on the menu and
jiu jitsu kaizen is now leading the
charge like demon slayer jiu jitsu
kaizen is a show mostly carried by how
good it looks the action's good the
characters are relatable and likable and
the powers are interesting that's
basically the recipe you use to turn in
a winner in the realm of action shonen
and jiu-jitsu kaizen passes the test
with flying colours every other episode
gave us a moment or a reveal that set
the whole anime community ablaze with
discussions and i'd say that you've got
to give a lot of credit to the animation
team for that
2021
and here we are 2021 and we're still
reeling from the effects of 2020 on the
bright side the anime industry seemed to
have recovered and stabilized from the
shock of early 2020 and there have been
a lot less delays now 2021's still not
over so we can't know for sure whether
this will hold but as far as an action
anime go i'll give the title this year
to vv florida's song i didn't know what
to expect out of vv fluoride diet song
at first despite the fact that the guy
behind re zero was involved in it it's
an understatement to say that the show
just blew me away with its incredible
animation and an often underrated aspect
in action anime the music and it
packages everything in a very
well-placed action anime that has quite
the depth in terms of themes one that's
becoming more and more relevant to
society gets integrated with technology
despite vv winning the title for 2021's
best action anime the year has had a lot
of strong contenders vivi just felt to
be the most complete for widespread
appeal for lack of a better term the
violence isn't extreme the fan service
is little to non-existent and the story
is well paced and has a good conclusion
you have 86 for those who want tragedy
drama and military in their action
series 2021 also unleashed mushoku
tensei known as the granddaddy of isakai
for a lot to the world and by the looks
of it it seems that it will stay for
good we have a long ride ahead if you
prefer something that involves time
loops however why don't you try tokyo
revengers it has a gripping plot that
continues to keep me on the edge of my
seat
that was a long discussion i'll be glad
to talk about it more on the comments
section come on show you year by year
picks as well and we can compare our
list honestly it's been quite a while
since i've had this much fun writing a
video because i've got to look at the
anime world from a perspective and see
how it has evolved over time if you
enjoyed this video as much as i did make
sure to hit that like button and share
this video with as many friends as you
can then maybe we can branch off to
other genres in the future best comedies
best mystery there's so much we can do
with this and i'll need your response to
see if i should keep making this new
category of videos if you had a great
time you can also check out the other
ways you can support the channel whether
that be through patreon or channel
memberships if you enjoy this type of
content where i get to be more elaborate
you can also go over to vini tube kai
where you'll have no shortage of long
videos like this don't forget to check
out our sponsors of this video
expressvpn bypass all those pesky region
locks and even browse sites not
available in your region with the ever
trustee expressvpn now that's it for
today and i hope that i can see you
again in my upcoming videos hopefully
with your new friends in tow until next
time have a great day
[Music]
[Music]
you